In objective C,
a pointer to an error is generally
passed as the last parameter
to a method that could fail.
If the method does indeed fail, a value
can be assigned to the error pointer.
Let's take a look at an example.
This method,
do something that might fail with error
could be used something like this.
Note that because we're passing a
pointer to a pointer, we use the double
asterisks in the method definition and
we use the ampersand in the method call.
If you take a look at the NSError class
reference, you'll notice that NSError
has three properties: domain,
code, and a user info dictionary.
These properties are access to
get additional information about
the cause of an error.
A similar error causing function
in Swift would look like this.
Swift uses the keyword throws
rather than an error parameter.
And here's what the method
call might look like.
Notice the do catch statement.
In Swift, if you have a method that
throws an error it's required that that
error be handled either with a try or
a do catch statement.
And Objective C on the other hand,
it's perfectly acceptable to
ignore an error completely.
The error itself might
look something like this.
You'll often see each error case
handled individually, like so.
Remember that enum members can
be associated with values.
One can use associated values to
provide information about errors.
And if we run this,
we can see the string associated with
each error printed to the console.